on touche en touche par en touche on
touche pas une petite virgule par ci une
petite effectivement on a souvent parlé
de couacs depuis le début de ce
quinquennat là on avait quand même une
image assez extraordinaire c'est le
sentiment que nous pouvons avoir capag
ligne et qu' il n'y a pas au sein du
gouvernement avec sa majorité son groupe
parlementaire
une cohérence intellectuelle une
cohérence idéologique une cohérence dans
les mesures ou effectivement grosso modo
ils ont fixé les bornes à ne pas
dépasser
et là on voit bien en écoutant trois
personnalités importantes le mil des
finances
le président du groupe le premier
ministre qu'on a trois positions
différentes et qu'on sait toujours pas
si on touchera donc moins ce que
j'attends déjà du gouvernement de la
majorité c'est qu'il y ait un front uni
si on veut tenir il faut un front uni
puis clavel cassions basse on a souvent
le sentiment on dit souvent que celui
qui le plus fort c'est celui qui est le
plus uni quel plus cohérent là les
français quand ils écoutent ça qu'est ce
qu'ils entendent x positions divergentes
au sein de la majorité et donc pour
tenir il faut dans un premier temps qui
les lignes de cohérence une colonne
vertébrale cohérente entre les uns et
les autres